let's now go to another guy who should
have no business anywhere near the
presidency Donald Trump Donald Trump
kicked off his New Hampshire wing of the
presidential campaign with a speech late
last week in that state in Manchester
New Hampshire it was one of the most
pathetic speeches I can recall from
Trump doing the woe is me stuff to a
degree I've never seen Trump's face as
usual his right eye almost completely
swollen shut Trump seeming agitated and
irritated but hilariously he kicked off
the event announcing this is a major
announcement he is no longer going to
use the Crooked nickname for Hillary
Clinton he is now going to call Joe
Biden crooked Joe Biden which is the
super creative and exciting but the
crowd seem to like it against crooked
Hillary Clinton
but
today I'm going to do this and I think
this could
yesterday because this is going to be a
major
announcement are you ready
[Music]
I will be retiring the name crooked from
Hillary Clinton and her moniker
and I'm gonna give her a new name I
don't know like maybe lovely Hillary or
beautiful Hillary but I'm going to
retire
the name crooked so that we can use the
name for Joe Biden because he'll be
known from now on as crooked Joe Biden
just absolutely electrifying the crowd
and of course as you all know that'll
get six million more people health care
so that's really something that is
actionable and important for a
presidential candidate to be talking
about
and this was that was one of the better
parts of the speech I hate to tell you
and the New Hampshire crowd
particularly sycophantic uh Trump
bringing up Kim Jong-un Kim Jong-un and
talking about how great of a
relationship he had with the dictator
South Korea we take care of their
economy we take care of everything by
the way being more critical of South
Korea than North Korea here I think we
take care of the military they're right
next door to Kim Jong-un he and I have a
very good relationship people would say
it's not good to have a good relay yeah
it's very good to have a good
relationship it really is
but he's not so happy with uh Biden he
says bad things about Biden but what I
really yeah Trump still seems to think
that when dictators like you it says
something good about you now of course
the truth is far more complicated than
that but this idea that we should be
concerned that Kim Jong-un doesn't like
Biden if it's true right uh no we should
have been concerned by the degree to
which Kim Jong-un felt he could roll
right over Trump and I actually recently
read uh the new Bradley hope book about
North Korea which I recommend to people
and it actually outlines a lot of the
ways in which the Trump foreign policy
towards North Korea to the extent that
there was foreign policy rather than
just Trump's ego running everything
um very much uh worth reading Bradley
Hope's new book about North Korea now at
another point during this speech Trump
uh quotes Lenin and refers to him as
Lenin and this is another one of these
things where we just don't really know
how Trump gets into this you know Lenin
Lenin did anyone ever hear of blood in
he said the vote counter is far more
important than the candidate has anyone
ever heard that's right Lennon Lenin as
they say
as they say in Russia I almost thought
Trump was going to be quoting some
lyrics from the great song Imagine
written of course by John lennine but he
didn't he was quoting Vladimir Lenin
there
um Trump seemingly justifying just not
debating in the Republican primary and
uh he talks about how Nixon and Reagan
and Bush didn't debate but of course you
know it was a completely different
situation in that they
there was not actually a primary in
those cases listen to this and this is
Trump starting to pre-lay the groundwork
to not participate in debates that might
not go well for him team as they go
prevents say bet on the opponent and
then they want to
do something under debates think of this
they want to debate they want to have I
have people at one half of one percent
one quarter of one percent one percent
three percent two percent four percent
seven percent and the Sanctus is very
low and crashing he's crashing and
burning don't forget when he came to me
he was at three percent
so he failed in his campaign he said sir
he endorsed him
I wish I could have done without but I
endorsed him anyone up a lot but he went
up and he won but when he came riveting
stuff as you can tell pain for a long
time he failed and now he's failing
again because now he's getting a chance
to campaign without Trump to put it
mildly to put it mildly
but so these debates you know uh
Nixon and Reagan and
uh bush bush number one uh others
no they didn't debate in the primers now
why didn't they debate in the primaries
it was because they were sitting
presidents running for re-election of
course the difference is Trump is not
currently the president although maybe
he thinks he is maybe his followers
think that he is so there's an open
Republican primary that's just the
reality Trump then weirdly turns on one
of his earliest and strongest supporters
Senator Lindsey Graham who was recently
on TV crying because Trump needed money
um he calls Lindsey Graham a progressive
this is a really strange moment it's
called reciprocal reciprocal
reciprocal
so if India charges our companies a
hundred we charge their companies 100 is
very simple and yet we have people in
Congress that say no I don't think
that's good anybody that says that's no
good very interesting Lindsey Graham the
progressive from South Carolina and the
crowd booze I thought they liked Lindsay
no he's a progressor
but he's got some good things too okay
but Lindsey Graham I said to him Lindsay
you got to go along with this we were
all set to get it done you got to go
along with this he says so let me let me
get this straight if they charge us we
charge them the same thing he said it's
not his strength other things are his
strength he said so they charge us we
charge them the same thing right yeah
you got my vote
that's so easy all right so I guess
Lindsey Graham you know when I think of
your classic Progressive I of course
think immediately of Lindsey Graham
really strange moment Trump did that
disgusting anti-transgender
weightlifting routine and this really
really titillated the crowd probably the
most electrifying moment of the speech
should I do it
[Applause]
all right that's Trump's visibly
straining to lift uh weights which is
really one of the favorite things I mean
the crowd was pretty dead throughout so
that that uh wound them up a little bit
Trump did deal with policy
sort of dealt with policy by saying he
will put in his travel ban again and he
mentions something about you saw that
right but of course it's like never
clear what he's talking about
and I will restore my travel ban to keep
radical Islamic terrorists out of our
country
you saw what happened four years four
years we went four years you saw that
right
we were very tough on that we don't want
our buildings blown up we don't want to
have problems to buy out of here all
right so um Trump
also took questions which was hilarious
because he didn't answer any of them
here's someone who asked him how will
you engage with Generation Z voters and
Trump just basically said oh we're
already doing it it's like oh all right
problem solved I guess thank you very
much God bless you my name is Christine
and I'm sure and
I'm sure we have hurricane first
Warriors like Caroline Levitt right how
do you plan how do you plan to engage
with Gen Z voters well I think we're
doing that and I tell you what you would
be shocked like Charlie Kirk and others
the job that they do with their with
their
youth it's a youth movement it really is
that's another movement you would be
shocked to see how popular we are on
college campuses much different than
what you read yeah well we we actually
have the election results from 2020 and
2022. uh they are not engaging with Gen
Z and in fact what's been going on with
abortion is probably only going to turn
off more gen Z voters so a ridiculous
speech but the crowd liked elements of
it so that gets us to our next question
who goes to a speech like this
when you're using websites and apps your
device sends out data about you into the
open who you are where you go things you
like that data then gets sold around for
advertising purposes which is why every
time I connect to the internet I use a
VPN to hide my IP address and our
sponsor private internet access is the
most trustworthy VPN on the market it's
the only VPN that has proven multiple
times in court they don't log your
activity private internet access
protects you from the prying eyes of
hackers your internet service provider
tech companies private internet access
is also super fast for streaming and for
downloads you can watch your favorite
streaming platforms as if you're in
another country like the UK to access
cool new content and with just one
account you can protect unlimited
devices all at the same time this is
really a game changer private internet
access is giving my audience 83 percent
off that's 203 a month plus four months
free go to Pia vpn.com Pacman the link
is down below